Every Creature From a worm insect bird
plant tree everybody all of them are
trying to be full-fledged lives if one
sees what's happening beneath the Earth
in terms of the root systems it is an
enormous effort for a plantar a tree to
become a full-fledged tree well an apple
tree is not trying to be an oak tree but
an apple tree wants to be a full-fledged
apple tree that effort is on in every
life so is it in human beings but the
problem with humanity is just this that
for every other creature nature is drawn
two lines Within These two lines they
live and die so their idea of
full-fledged is hitting the ceiling of
their life but if a human being hits a
ceiling he gets frustrated and miserable
this process of evolution has delivered
to us to a place where there is only the
bottom line there is no Top Line though
some human beings are trying to breach
the bottom line and go below so
essentially what human life is when life
was in the other forms of life that you
see on the planet nature determined a
certain compulsive instinctive ways of
functioning once to become human these
lines have been removed what you call as
human potential is not of any kind of
measurable limit it can go as far as you
desire for us as far as you have the
courage to walk need motivation put your
top 10 with police Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I quit on
my business partner I was making 300
bucks a month and I didn't have the
motivation to keep going and the thing
that got me through was studying the
stories of entrepreneurs who've had
massive success and I hope that in
sharing these stories with you you find
a motivation to keep going and if I'm
being honest I still need the source for
myself today too so today let's learn
from one of the best sad Guru and my
take on his top 50 rules of success
enjoy
so when we say human potential
unleashing human potential
it is not about reaching the peak
it is a trajectory
because what our life is
is a combination of a certain amount of
time and energy
time is rolling away for all of us at
the same pace
if you sit it rolls away if you sleep it
rolls away if you do something it goes
away if you don't do anything it goes
away you're happy or miserable it goes
away
time is running out for all of us
so it's only the energy that you can
do different things with if you bring
your energies to a certain level of
intensity and possibility
what somebody does in 10 years you may
do it in one year
this means if you live here for 100
years it feels like in people's impact
that you have created it feels like you
lived here for a thousand years
simply because you have managed your
life energies in a certain way
so for me a human being being impactful
means
how conscious have you become this is
very important because if you're in
compulsive Cycles then your energy gets
wasted in so many things if you absorb
people
in a day let's say let's take 24 hours
in that anyway most people by
prescription in America they sleep for
eight hours
so eight hours means one third of life
is gone
in the remaining two-thirds they have to
eat they have to you know shower
bathroom this that all this another two
three hours gone
so literally 50 percent of life is gone
daily basis just for basic maintenance
of this life
fifty percent of the time is gone in
maintenance remaining fifty percent what
they have if you look at every single
move that they may make with their body
their thought process their emotions you
will see a whole lot of it is happening
in compulsive Cycles
or in other words if you are little
sensitive to life you will realize you
are the biggest issue in your life
so this is one thing that I'm trying to
do with people that you are never the
issue in your life
I'm not the issue my thought my emotion
my body is never the issue
my thought my emotion my energy and my
body are my instruments a function they
are not impediments in my life but I
would say for 90 of the human beings
their own body then the compulsions of
the body the compulsions of their
thought the compulsions of their
emotions
or ruling them most of the time you are
a product of this planet yes or no
whatever nonsense individuals may think
about themselves we are all just a
pop-up from this planet you've seen
those pop-ups on the computer screen pop
pop yes
you just a pop-up
you'll be gone
you can't believe you will be gone ah me
I will be gone yes all the very smart
people countless number of people who
walk this planet before and you and me
where the hell are they are not a sign
all became top soil isn't it so one day
pop-ups aren't you a pop-up
you may think you have a great life and
this and that as far as the Earth is
concerned it's just recycling its soil
yes throws you up and draws you back
throws you up and draws you back
so in this little pop-up the important
thing and the most important thing is
you create sensitivity within you such
sensitivity that every dimension of Life
comes into your experience
before you fall dead is it not important
you experience this life in this fullest
possible scale
yes or no
experience means people think we must
party every day
no no same damn thing how many times you
will do
there is much more for the human life to
explore you must become sensitive when I
say sensitive because the word sensitive
is used in the wrong way in the sense
when people say oh she's very sensitive
we are supposed to understand uh she
will get hurt for just about anything
yes no being sensitive to life and being
ego sensitive are two different things
being sensitive to life means if you
walk into this Hall you experience
everything that's here you don't miss a
thing if you walk outside you don't miss
a thing every dimension of life should
come into your experience what a vision
and vision means is
say everybody has desires
desire is an incremental way of
enhancing our life
today you desire I must have a home
tomorrow you desire I must have this
money tomorrow you desire something else
these are incremental ways of arranging
and rearranging Our Lives which are
needed to do a few things
when you say I am a Visionary what
you're saying is
I have a larger desire
which is not about just incremental
Improvement of my life
desire is about me always
vision is an all in all-inclusive
process
[Music]
so this itself is a phenomenal thing if
people instead of having desires if they
have a vision
vision is always all-inclusive
desire is personal
desire leads to incremental changes and
improvements Vision can transform the
whole situation so it's very important
that there is nothing to miss out in
life life is happening to all of us
question is only if I miss this party am
I missing out something
if I miss this examination I am missing
out something if I miss this job am I
missing out something this is simply
because
right now who you are is not internally
Managed IT is externally stimulated when
you step out into the world if you leave
it to the people to decide what happens
within you they're going to drive you
crazy in no time
here it's all managed for you you're not
managing this it's managed for you what
should happen to you what should not
happen to you somebody else is managing
it when you step out on the street if
you leave it to other people's hands
that they can decide whether you're
happy or unhappy you're going to be
miserable for sure
because they want to do many things
what happens within you must be
determined by you isn't it also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I designed a special
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there no
technology is harmful
it is just that
when
human mind is in a certain level of
destructive mode every technology is
harmful
everything
you can take your laptop and slit
somebody's head
does it mean to say
computers are dangerous
suppose a few incidents happen like this
in many offices it happened let's say in
10 different offices it so happened
somebody took Apple Air and slipped
somebody's head
does it mean to say laptops are
dangerous
no human being so stupid
whatever comes their way they know how
to turn it against themselves
when they've turned their own brains
against themselves
what else do you want
[Music]
now there are
technology D addiction centers
you know this
like there are drug de addiction alcohol
the addiction
now technology the addiction centers
simply because we are in a compulsive
mode
if we start eating we don't know when to
stop eating
that's a problem big problem
quite a big problem
if we start drinking we don't know when
to start drinking stop drinking
if we start shopping we don't know when
to stop shopping
if you start using the phone we don't
know when to stop using the phone
so the problem is not of Technology the
problem is of compulsiveness
when we say compulsiveness it's just
absence of Consciousness isn't it
if we were conscious human beings
we would use everything for our
well-being and everybody's well-being
because we are compulsive
we start doing something we don't know
how to stop
endlessly we will do the same silly
thing
so whether it's virtual reality or
artificial intelligence or anything or
anything
the problem is not of Technology never
because they are just devices
created by us
we are supposed to use it for our
well-being
that's ideal isn't it
but see most of the Cutting Edge
technology always goes into military
usage in the world
obviously we don't know how to use it
for a well-being we are always using it
to destroy something
this has been the thing always not just
now
because we've never worked on human
consciousness
if human beings lived consciously if the
leadership in the world was a conscious
leadership a question of using
technology against human well-being or
the well-being of anything wouldn't
arise isn't it
is technology means enhancement of our
capability isn't it
if you wish about what may happen or may
not happen right
fear is not about what is
what we are experiencing right now what
will happen
is always the fear
or in other words your fear is about
something which is not yet
your fear is about something which does
not exist
this is all management people if there
were a few
somebody from a Psychiatry Department
you could have asked them
if I have fear about something that does
not exist what is my condition they
would have a title for you
yes let me just close by I think you can
always cancel that is also a premier
Institution
we are suffering something which doesn't
even exist
yes
if you're suffering something that
doesn't even exist it is not about life
it is not about education it's not about
career it is just about your mind being
out of control
is that not an important aspect that you
should manage first before we allow you
to manage an industry or a business is
it not important first of all you learn
to at least manage your mind hello
isn't it important if you do not know
how to manage your mind what the hell
are you going to manage in the world
managers are all freaking out and
growing ulcers in their stomachs
yes today it's become normal if you are
a CEO by 45 if you don't have an ulcer
you're not a great CEO
because
you are managing by accident like this
the fear comes because there is an
accidental possibility isn't it
tell me let's say you don't know how to
ride a bicycle you sat on it it was on
stand you were just peddling for fun and
it came off stand and started rolling
anxiety or no
started rolling faster fear or no
very fast Terror or no
[Music]
it's not because bicycle produces Terror
it is just that you don't know how to
ride
if you know how to ride faster it goes
the better it is
hmm
isn't it faster it goes the better it is
the very very uh basis why we created a
bicycle is because we wanted to go
faster than walking
that's the idea but if you do not know
how to write how much fear it creates
right now your problem is not with the
world your problem is not with your
education your problem is your education
system right from kindergarten hasn't
told you a damn thing about how to
manage yourself people are having
Disturbed sleep because of the way
they're keeping their minds if you are
in a comfortable state of mind if you go
to sleep the body knows when to wake up
one day it may sleep for this many hours
another day it may sleep for half the
amount of time it's perfectly fine body
needs rest body does not need sleep
restfulness is not in the hours it is in
the drop of metabolic activity that you
have
generally in deep Sleep your metabolism
drops approximately eight percent you
sit for somebody your metabolic activity
can drop up to 24 the restfulness that
you are gaining in meditation is three
times more profound than sleep then one
thing that will happen to you is sleep
quota will come down suddenly say
everybody is looking for tidbits of life
give me three points with which I will
make my life one Mantra with which
everything will be solved that's not how
life is it's a comprehensive process
the simple way to look at it is like
this
today you know because of medical
Sciences
that your entire body
in a way is a chemical soup
the question is only is it a great super
a lousy soup
so if it's a great soup
then it tastes wonderful for you and
tastes wonderful for everybody around
you
if it's a lousy soup
then you have to manage with
presentation
when the chef is bad you know
he decorates it all right these days
food comes with flowers on it
never ever outside situations will
happen 100 your way
but what happens within you if it's
happening 100 your way you will be in
the best possible State always you will
keep yourself in the best possible way
are you as good as somebody that's not
the point
are you full-fledged that is a point if
you go outside in the garden
and try to catch an ant
the bhu ant
who is born here who's grown up here and
probably he'll die here
that bhu and if you try to catch him
he'll say okay to hell with my life okay
crush me if you want
is it so
he'll do everything to protect himself
he values his life isn't it
very much
tiny little creature that we may not
even notice we may step on him without
even seeing him unfortunately
but he values his life immensely
does he know
he's got Spark
but you
a human being
at least on this planet you're the peak
of evolution
physiologically at least
yes if other behavioral aspects if you
may have questions
but physiologically at least the most
evolved creature on the planet
what the most evolved creature on the
planet means is
it has the most complex neurological
system
and it has the highest level of cerebral
capability
that means you can think you can
remember you have memory
you have a very Vivid sense of memory
and a fantastic sense of imagination
an ant doesn't have such a vivid sense
of memory nor does he have any great
imagination here some
but
he has a presence of mind about the life
that he is living
because
the education systems that you are going
through right from kindergarten level is
such
that it is about everything except you
it's about everything else
somebody is PhD in tourism somebody is
PhD in biotechnology somebody is PhD in
something
about this
how does this function there is no
attention at all
a human being functions you know you
have a caliber of a temple here
what this means is a human being exists
in three times
he lives because of the richness of his
memory how rich is your memory
determines what you will do and what you
will not do right now isn't it so
so memory is important
the present experience is important and
how Vivid is your imagination for
tomorrow is very important
right now the problem is these things
have all gotten mixed up
because discipline of Faculty has simply
not come
nothing has been taught to our children
that there needs to be discipline means
people think English kind of discipline
walking like this like idiots
discipline of Faculty is not there
because of this your own mind turns
against you
what happened 10 years ago you still
suffer
hello
what may happen Day After Tomorrow you
already suffer
because there's no discipline of faculty
you don't know how to use your memory
you don't know how to use your
imagination your memory Makes You Suffer
you imagine makes imagination makes you
suffer and you think you're suffering
your life you are not suffering your
life you are only suffering the two
greatest faculties of Being Human Vivid
sense of memory and a fantastic sense of
hum imagination isn't it so
if you suffer the greatest faculties
that you have what can we do with you
if you suffer ailment
understandable
if you suffer a disability
understandable if you suffer your
ability
hopeless case
yes or no
you're suffering your capabilities if
you are suffering your disability it's
all right you're suffering your
capabilities I must tell you this about
four or five months ago I think you
might have seen it on the news
a young lady 34 year old lady
who was a television anchor in Hyderabad
jumped off the fifth floor window
kill herself
left a note
nobody is responsible for my death my
brain is my enemy
how many million years it took to get
this brain to this size and now it
becomes your enemy
she articulated this but this is true
with almost 90 percent of the human
beings they are suffering their own
intelligence isn't it
if you take away half their brain
if you take away half their brain they
will be peaceful
foreign
yes
and that is why a whole bunch of idiots
are going about saying that the ultimate
goal of life is peace of mind such
people will only rest in peace
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
it's like sunlight
sunlight is available to everybody but
only those who open their eyes will see
that's the way it is
but is it not there is it there only for
me not for you there's no such thing
it's available for everybody
it's just that are you receptive
when we talk about receptivity
see the entire process of yoga the word
yoga itself means this the word yoga
means Union Union
means what right now in most people's
experience
it is me versus universe
this is how people are experiencing life
otherwise why continuous anxiety fear
they think they are fighting for their
life all the time why they are fighting
the whole universe
individual and the universal
being in competition
with the universe is a stupid thing to
do see right now what are the
instruments of your experience
you know you're here only because you
can see hear smell taste and touch this
is the only way you know that you're
here right now
suppose you doze off don't okay
suppose you doze off
you don't know that you're here isn't it
yes even though you're here your heart
is beating everything is functioning the
world is on we are all here but you
won't know that you are here nor will
you know that I am here or anybody else
is here isn't it yes all that's happened
is life is on Full on even within you
only thing is these five sensory organs
have shut down
so your entire experience of life right
now is happening because you can see
here smell taste and touch
just look at the nature of the sensory
organs in the very nature
their Outward Bound isn't it
can you roll your eyeballs Inward and
scan yourself no
there's a shall I give you a bad example
sir
your our nose is located right above our
mouth
suppose you don't brush your teeth for
three days
[Music]
though this nose is right here it won't
tell you you have not brushed your teeth
the whole room will know you have not
brushed your teeth but you will not know
this is the human predicament
it's very easy to see what's wrong with
this guy what's wrong with her what's
wrong with her
very it takes a lot of observation to
see what's wrong with this
that level of keenness of observation is
missing in most people they need to
cultivate that if your friend uh is
doesn't not do well you'll feel sad
about it if he does very well you'll
feel very sad about it
so you have fixed yourself in such a way
whichever way you cannot be happy
[Music]
you you were in a self-defeating mode no
matter what happens you will not be
happy
if you want to understand what I am
saying you go and stand out on one of
the main streets in Bangalore City
I'll leave the poor people who are
selling karlekai on the street side
leave them
people who are driving there only look
at those BMWs Mercedes and majorities
and whatever is going around in
Bangalore City only look at the dream
cars okay because many of you may have
dreams also of this
just look at all these people you think
they are in a perfusion of joy driving
this car like that no only in case it's
a stolen car you see the joy
[Applause]
otherwise
no
so success has not brought joy to them
if they're failed of course they are
frustrated
because the very mode of approach is
like this
if this mode of approach comes whichever
way it's not going to work
because it's not even about you it's
always about somebody here it's never
about you
the simple thing is this
see
if your joy your sadness your happiness
your misery is determined by something
or somebody around you the chances of
you being joyful in your life is remote
yes or no
is it true that Human Experience is
Created from within
hello hello I'm asking all of you is it
true that Human Experience Joy or misery
Agony or ecstasy Madness or sanity
everything is Created from inside
at least if you're a manager
if you're going to be a manager at least
what is happening from within you must
happen your way because essentially
management means having situations the
way we want it
yes
management means what having situations
the way we want it
well if the world is not happening your
way at least this one must be happening
your way otherwise what kind of
management is this
here there's only one person
huh here there are a thousand people
they may not listen to you they got
their own stuff
but here there's only one person at
least here what you want must happen
isn't it if what you want happened would
you keep yourself blissed out or
miserable what's your choice you must
choose I'm going to bless you now
if you had a choice would you be rather
be blissed out or miserable
no
blessed out of course
so if such a thing is not happening then
all these problems come
if things work it is a problem if they
don't work it's a problem if you get a
seat in this institution it's a problem
if you cannot get out of this it's a
problem
you like this place so much you don't
mind staying here it's not like that
you must get in and you must get get out
ahead of others everything it's never
about you it's always about something
else
outside is a variable situation
who these people are today tomorrow we
don't know what they will say
yes tomorrow morning we don't know what
they will say if your way of being is
determined by all these people
then you are a mess you're bound to be a
mess when it comes to what you want to
do
uh
you must think clearly it's very
important
thinking clearly means the question is
not about what will get me this what
will get me that
are you is your life precious to you all
of you I'm asking your life is it
precious to you so before you invest
this life
into something
you must look whether today if I invest
my life into this after 25 years will it
still mean a lot to me
after 50 years will it still mean a lot
to me at the end of my life you will
turn back under a look will I be proud
of this or will I be ashamed of what I
am doing right now
it doesn't matter what other people say
but you should not do anything that you
did you it doesn't matter people say so
many things
everybody has opinion it's their
business
but you don't do something that you will
feel ashamed of isn't it
then you go turning against yourself
somebody turns against you you can leave
them and go somewhere else
if you turn against yourself you'll have
to live with it forever
so this is all you have to look at it
somebody something will get you money
something will get you comfort that's
not the point what you choose to do will
it give you a life when I say give it
give you a life are you just trying to
make a living or are you trying to make
a life out of this is important
making a living is not an issue a worm a
insect a bird an animal all of them are
making their life making a living isn't
it so
that even making a life out of it but
definitely they're making a living
so making a living with such a big brain
is not an issue
earning your food is not a issue making
a living is not an issue only problem is
you want to live like somebody else
that's an endless problem
I want to live is not a problem I want
to live like you this is a problem
so it is important if you consider your
life as a precious life you must make
sure you make a wonderful life out of
this see as we sit here this is my body
that is your body do what you want these
two things will not become one
this is my mind that is your mind do
what you want these things will not
become one they may overlap on some
issues and we may feel that we are one
with each other but my mind is my mind
your mind is your mind isn't it
but there is no such thing as my life
and your life
this is a living Cosmos
you captured a little bit I captured a
little bit
that's about it but now we think this is
my life and that is your life there is
no such thing this is a living cop
Cosmos you've blown a small bubble
somebody might have blown a little
bigger bubble
did you blow snow bubbles when you were
young oh yeah you still do yes
so when you blue soap bubbles
somebody had this big bubble somebody
else had that big bubble oh went on
saying this is my bubble this is your
bubble but poop it went once it goes
poop
you did not say this is Maya and this is
your air
similarly there is no such thing as my
life and your life
there is just a living Cosmos if you
capture more life
then you will see you have more grace
the depth Dimension and scope of your
life is determined by how much life you
capture within you it doesn't matter
what kind of body you have what kind of
intelligence you have if you have not
captured substantial life within you you
will live a small life that's how it is
how do you do this there are systematic
ways of approaching this or simply by
involvement and exuberance by commitment
people may capture a larger life
by absolutely being committed to
something focused on something somebody
May capture a certain amount of life
which is more than what is considered
normal you talked one time I thought
this was so interesting about how every
time you get a belief it's like a
conclusion in every conclusion is a
death unto itself and it's like shutting
a door on something yes otherwise see
you just see
you look at your own picture when you're
five years of age it's like this
slowly it's becoming like this what is
it you're dying in installments
the more conclusions you make the less
alive you become this all that's
happened to people they call this
knowledge
this is not knowledge this is just
conclusions that you're drawing about
everything
see with all this scientific exploration
the fact is that even today we do not
know one single atom in its entirety we
know how to use them we know how to use
everything on this planet but we don't
know a damn thing about anything
over 90 percent or 99 of an atom is
empty we don't know what that emptiness
contains over 99 of the cosmos is empty
we don't know what that is
so this is like I give you a million
piece jigsaw
but you found in your hands you have
only three of them with this three you
make a picture and you're euphoric that
you made a picture
well I'm sorry
there are million pieces to this
has anybody gathered all the pieces no
then don't make a picture there is
thought and there is emotion
people think these two things are saying
different things they are not saying
different things the way you think is
the way you emote isn't it so
right now if I think oh she's the most
wonderful person on the planet
I just have to think then my emotions
become sweet towards her
now I think she's the most horrible
creature on the planet
now my emotions become nasty yes or no
I cannot think she's horrible and have
Sweet Emotions
I cannot think she's wonderful and have
nasty emotions isn't it so
but today I thought she is the most
wonderful person and my sweetness was
flowing
suddenly she did something tomorrow that
I don't like I think she's horrible
thought is agile it changes Direction
Just Like That Emotion is little sappy
it takes time to turn around
so that period you struggle as if there
are two dimensions of
thing happening because thought is
saying one thing emotion is still going
sweet because it takes time to become
nasty
everybody struggles but it catches apart
no after some time hello
today you touch his wonderful sweetness
was flowing tomorrow she did something
you don't like you thought she's
horrible man the thought is clearly
saying she's horrible but emotions are
struggling because they can't turn
quickly they take time to turn but after
a week or 10 days or two months
depending on how deeply you're engaged
thank you
after some time emotion catches up with
the thought emotion also says yes she's
not horrible so well let's be nasty to
her
so they're not speaking different
languages one is agile another is little
slow in his Corners if you focus
whatever you're doing right now it
doesn't matter what it is
how simple an act you're doing right now
it doesn't matter if you're absolutely
devoted to that that you're doing right
now
depending upon various aspects things
will unfold
but
because of Western influences we become
too goal oriented
goal-oriented means we are interested in
the consequence but we are not
interested in the process
if you are not interested in the process
you should not be an artist
yes
process is an end in itself
if you are absolutely devoted to the
process
depending upon various aspects something
will come out
but now we are interested in the
consequence
not in the process this
goal-orientedness I want to get there I
want to get there where the hell do you
want to get
no I want to win the race
see if you treat Life as a race
if you have to win it you have to get to
the Finish Line soon isn't it
you want to
hello
if you get to the Finish Line ahead of
all these people you won the race
you know what the finish line is
we'll be negotiating where to bury you I
can show you thousands of people around
me today
when they came
they thought they won't do anything
significant half of them not half 70
percent of them are dropouts from
schools and colleges and everything
but you will see after a few years of
sadhana suddenly they are functioning in
ways that you won't believe possible
recently we had a business uh you know
event called Insight where over 200 CEOs
from across the world are coming and
participating
all of them Wonder
why our organizations don't run as
smoothly and efficiently as yours
I said that's because I all have all
dropouts who are no good for anything
they have a devotion in their heart they
are devoted to what they're doing that's
all
because they're absolutely devoted to
what they are doing they may not be mbas
they may not be from iits and Iams
they're simple people but because
they're absolutely devoted they do
wonderful things of all the pieces of
engineering on this planet
of many pieces of engineering a tree is
a fantastic engineering even a mountain
is fantastic engineering because it
stood there for a million years that
means it must be good engineering isn't
it
yes something that stands there for a
million years must be well engineered
of all this the most sophisticated piece
of engineering is human mechanism
isn't it so
hello
most sophisticated of all the pieces of
engineering
now because it's a sophisticated piece
of engineering
it needs a certain level of attention
otherwise you don't figure it
now that we gave you such a highly
you know I take piece of engineering I
am asking you did you read the users
menu
I I think there is no user manual or no
how can I make such a fantastic piece of
engineering without a user's manual
maybe it doesn't come with a booklet
attached to your neck when you were born
but indications must be there isn't it
how to use it
huh is it true
somebody who's an athlete or a gymnast
or someone else like that learns to use
their body then a whole lot of other
people
yes obviously at least one aspect of the
physical engineering of the body
they seem to have read the user's manual
about the physical aspects
is it true certain people are able to
use their mind better than others
maybe there are another part of the
user's manual
so now uh With This Heart manual and the
Brain manual
see the problem is most people are
prejudiced against the brain
this is a question or always comes to be
sadhguru I want to meditate but thoughts
are coming
the common question everywhere
I asked them see I'll make you meditate
we will stop the liver we'll stop the
kidney we'll stop the heart we'll stop
everything okay
so you want the liver to function when
you're meditating
you wonder kidneys to function you want
even the spleen to function you want the
heart to function but you don't want
your brain to function for some reason
this is simply because
brain is a new equipment that you got in
the evolutionary process
this level of cerebral development
happened more recently compared to the
other systems if you could open any
mammal they all have all these parts
isn't it every part that you have here
all of them have
even if you open a frog
most of you your biology Department
even if we open a frog almost everything
that you have he also has isn't it
it is only the big difference is only
the cerebral development which is a more
recent happening
because it's a more recent happening
most people have not figured how to
handle it
so users manual is very important you
don't read a user's manual
just before you discard the machine you
read it in the first few days isn't it
hello
if you buy a phone do you want to read
the user's manual in the first three
days or after three years when you're
throwing it away
it was three days isn't it so knowing
how this functions is very important
never did ever
heart generate any thought or intention
well when you looked at the young girl
heartbeat
more that doesn't mean it's saying
anything it's just trying to compensate
for the other levels of excitement
that's happening fundamentally if people
understand that the source of human
experiences within you
ecstasy pleasure of pain everything
comes from within you if you understand
this much
if I understand
suppose right now I think I'm miserable
because of you
there's no solution for my life isn't it
because all you have to do is walk in
front of my home I will become miserable
so simple it is you don't have to kill
me you just have to walk around in front
of me I will die within myself every day
if I understand the source of my joy and
misery are within me
then you know what's the obvious choice
Joy the obvious choice isn't it
so this one fundamental thing has to get
across to all the human beings on this
planet
your experience is entirely determined
by you
this is what the word Karma means
unfortunately it's become something else
here
Karma means action that means when we
say your life is your karma we are
saying your life is entirely your making
100 percent
what happens in the world there are many
many forces involved what happens within
me it's 100 me
100 isn't it yes
if you don't take charge of this
then you're an accidental life when
you're an accidental life anxiety is
very natural
isn't it suppose you're driving
accidentally
that is you don't know what's happening
and you're simply somehow going anxiety
is natural or no yes
any accidental moment creates anxiety
so this is why Consciousness means this
that you have taken charge of the
instruments of life
which on most fundamental level is our
physiological and psychological space
you're taking charge of this now your
health your happiness your joy your
ecstasy your misery everything is in
your hands
you exercise them as you want people
keep asking me coming to me and asking
me sadhguru please bless us nothing
should happen to us I say hey what kind
of blessing is this my blessing is let
everything happen to you
everything that's life must happen to
you have you come here to avoid life or
have you come here to experience life
please you must make a decision right
now
have you come here to avoid life or to
experience life
experience life all the different
dimensions of what this life holds must
happen to you isn't it so
if you come to avoid life
there's an ocean right here
you can jump into the ocean
see if you want to avoid life
you must die
it's a more efficient way of doing
things isn't it you're alive when you
try to avoid life you'll become
miserable
if you feel insecure that's what you
will do you will try to avoid life
when you're alive and try to avoid life
it will cause immense misery
when you're alive you live
when you die you die don't get up from
the dead see there is scientific
evidence to show
at least 20 percent of your energy right
now as you sit here in a restful state
is being consumed by your brain
if you bring this down
that your brain is not unnecessarily
fluctuating and you know
hopping mad
all the time
if it learns to still be still and do
only what's needed
an enormous sense of personal power will
develop
you can't do this with your mind right
now if you try to stop it it'll hop even
more crazy
good with your body
your words and your physical moments
reduce it by 50 percent
if you want to look at this look at this
you want to look at that look at that
don't do this this
with your body and your
utterances if you do this slowly it will
also start manifesting in your mind it
will not do unnecessary things
when you don't know unnecessary things
the energy that you have slowly
transforms itself into potential power
if you have practices to keep yourself
so open and so joyful
life that's it what else
life is an openness death is closing
isn't it
death is a closure life is a possibility
if you're just alive everything is open
tell me can you be alive suppose you
don't like me
so you don't want to inhale what I
exhale stop breathing and exist for some
time let me see possible yes without
breathing for a little while
how is little how much is little for you
to hold my breath yeah
I don't know 30 seconds 10 seconds 10
minutes definitely not 10 minutes
so I'm saying if you don't like me your
dislike will not go away in 30 seconds
isn't it yeah for sure suppose I hate
you I don't want to breathe inhale what
you exhale
I will die Within Myself isn't it yes
yes this all people are doing to
themselves I like this guy I don't like
that guy this is uh somebody I love that
somebody I hate this is belongs to me
this doesn't belong to me they're just
killing themselves step by step
they are planning to die in installments
if you want to live here you are you
must make up your mind whether you want
to live or you want to die you want to
know the certainty of death in life
this is called belief this is called
belonging this is called identification
because you are trying to find the
certainty of death in the seamless
process of life this happened at the
Cincinnati airport in Ohio United States
people had lined up to check in at the
airline ticket booth
one man just skipped the line and came
straight in the front and thrust his
ticket
the lady at the counter she said sir
there is a line
he said no no I'm in a hurry
she said everybody's in a hurry you're
on the same plane
please stand in the line
then he said do you know who I am
she looked at him promptly picked up the
microphone and said there is a man here
who does not know who he is can somebody
help him
so
who am I
is not a Christian that you ask somebody
it's a question that you ask yourself
make it more and more profound something
will get you money something will get
you comfort that's not the point what
you choose to do will it give you a life
when I say give it give you a life are
you just trying to make a living or are
you trying to make a life out of this is
important
making a living is not an issue a worm a
insect a bird an animal all of them are
making their life making a living isn't
it so
that even making a life out of it but
definitely they're making a living
so making a living with such a big brain
is not an issue
earning your food is not an issue making
a living is not an issue only problem is
you want to live like somebody else
that's an endless problem
I want to live is not a problem I want
to live like you this is a problem
so
it is important if you consider your
life as a precious life you must make
sure you make a wonderful life out of
this don't pursue enlightenment
you cannot pursue enlightenment
how can you pursue something that you do
not know
if you pursue something you will pursue
only what you know
what is the point pursuing something
that you already know
what is the point in running after
something that you already know
so if you have to step into something
that you do not know
[Music]
the only thing is just to keep walking
keep a steady Direction and keep walking
maybe it's the wrong direction it
doesn't matter just keep working after
all planet is round
inevitably
if you keep walking and keep straight
walking not round and round
if you just keep straight walking
you will inevitably get somewhere
nobody can take it away from you
you know
if you have a dog at home you would know
this if you just tickle him in the tail
he will go
chasing his own tail
okay A lot of people are doing that
[Music]
they don't tell they're chasing
even Enlightenment is their own Tale
nobody told you there is such a thing
but
definitely you can see
from one person to another person
one person seems to be little better off
simply the way they are not not because
of their money not because of their
wealth not because of their
qualifications simply the way they sit
and stand somebody seems to be better
off than somebody else
yes or no
so there is room and scope for
improvement
relentlessly improve let's see where it
gets you
but if you have fancy ideas of what is
enlightenment
then you will chase that silly idea
and that idea is never enlightenment
because it's your idea in your book you
talk about something I thought was so
interesting to set the faucet to a
certain drip rate and do nothing but
focus on the dripping of the fossa for
like seven minutes or something the idea
is to pay attention to something which
has no relevance to you
say people are have divided the universe
this is important this is not important
this person is important for me this
person is not important this is
important for me that's not important
for me you divided the universe you will
never know anything this way
indiscriminate Focus indiscriminate
attention I am not attending to you
because you are somebody with a cobra in
your heart all right
it doesn't matter who I speak to who I
am with I'm the same way
indiscriminate
only when your attention and involvement
is indiscriminate thus the universe open
up to you
you have discriminated naturally you
close you know people come to me and say
sadhguru I want to walk the spiritual
path
I say okay
be here for three days let's see what we
can do so in no such group day after
tomorrow my uncle's daughter's birthday
I have to go
oh you want to get enlightened
and Day After Tomorrow uncle's
daughter's birthday also all right
we got one and a half days
you do one thing you do this this and
this I said but I don't like this
all right I'll give them a small piece
of paper
and say okay write down things that you
like we'll do only do that
so they won't believe it in this entire
universe most people like only three or
four things
when you are so constipated in your head
that you lack only three or four people
or three or four things in your life how
do you want to open up to the existence
because life is happening because of its
openness
this is a fundamental difference between
death and life is people are thinking
it's just breath all right on one level
that is also openness whether you allow
this to happen or you don't allow it to
happen
whether you did it consciously or
unconsciously but it's happening isn't
it openness is on every subatomic
particle is in communication with
everything that's why this is going on
breath is happening so much is happening
in connection with everything it is only
in openness you're alive
as you close doors you are dying in
installments
dying in installments is torture
see
life is fantastic if you're alive and
fully alive
if you're dead it's good at least the
neighbors may think so
this may sound very not so compassionate
but I'm saying everybody dies you and me
will die all right
if you're dead it's the game is over
but if you're half dead oh
this is endless torture to yourself when
you are being tortured of course you
will share it with everybody else if you
come to terms with your mortality
Security in security all these things
will go
you are living on a daily basis as if
you are forever
the fundamental awareness that this is
motto this is here only for a limited
amount of time if this was a you know a
normal conscious thing for you
you would put your life to best use
for sure
and
if you come to terms with that one thing
there would be no insecurity because
there is nothing to gain nothing to lose
in this life
you came with nothing whatever the hell
is happening you're on the prophet side
yes or no
isn't it so did you come with investment
no you come with nothing
so whatever the hell is happening you're
always on the prophet's side isn't it
and anyway they don't allow you to take
a container
in the end
so all you have is how profound intense
and beautiful is your experience of life
so don't make too much fuss about it
you're acting as if you're going to lose
something
no there's nothing to lose nothing to
gain because
you come and you go you may think oh my
life my life no it's your your life on
this planet is like a pop-up on the
computer screen you've seen this pop-ups
you just pop up and pop out
in the meantime will you rise and shine
is the only question
all right
so if anywhere you shine sometimes you
may be seen by people sometimes you may
not be seen by people the important is
you sh you're shining within yourself
and that's all that matters if people
have eyes they will see it if they have
no eyes they won't see it that's their
problem
but
you are living an intense and profound
life that's all that matters here if you
understand this and if you bring this
into your life
insecurity will not happen because
security can happen only in depth you
may be wonderful but you are not loyal
to your wonderfulness
you are joyful
you are sometimes Blissful you're even
loving
but not loyal to these qualities
a beautiful flower throws out fragrance
the flower is very loyal
no matter if you pluck it also it's
still fragrant if the cow eats it also
it's fragrant if the bee messes around
also it's fragrant it never got angry
and turned into a skunk ever
but you are not like that you are
wonderful like this if somebody pokes
you you will become a skunk
only when you're in a pleasant state of
experience your body and your brain
works at its best there's no argument
about them there's enough evidence to
show that
so whatever impact or success or
reaching goals or growth or whatever you
say
on one level in the physical world it's
about how well you harness your
physiological and your psychological
process isn't it
whether your body and mind works against
you or works for you this is a big
difference
so there is enough evidence to show only
when you're in Pleasant levels of
experience this happens best
so obviously Joyce first
then growth if you're joyful constantly
and you have no fear of suffering
because you understand all Human
Experience comes from within you and so
you have managed to create the kind of
experience that you want now growth is
possible and brittled if you have the
fear of falling down and suffering you
will not go very high isn't it
perception happens to you in five
different dimensions seeing hearing
smelling tasting touching this is how
you're perceiving life
this data data has gathered within you
only because this data has gathered
within you now you are able to walk on a
round Planet which spins it's not a
small thing
it is not a small thing that you are
able to walk on a spinning round ball
because all this data has gathered
through five senses it is not
intellectual information but it is a
perceptional information if this
information is not there you won't be
able to walk actually
you will not be able to walk straight
this is what is happening for people
when some people lose their memory and
things like that suddenly they become
unstable in their body because some of
the data is gotten disconnected with
their system so this data that you
perceive is most important that's what a
child is all the time drinking up
everything you see how the child is
looking at everything because he wants
to drink up as much data as possible
because instinctively he knows without
the data he will not be able to function
so how attentive you are how attentive
your eyes are how attentive your ears
nose tongue and touch is accordingly you
have that much you know that much usable
information so why one person is more
efficient while you are an athlete why
one person is able to catch a damn ball
another person can't catch the damn
thing what is it because that level of
attention of exactly how that ball will
behave how you can anticipate where it
will go this is not there intellectually
suppose you have a PhD in football you
think you can play football
uh if you have a PhD no I think you need
to experience it as well if you just
study it only yeah no that is that is
not experience it's perception you are
you're watching it out of your Keen
interest you're watching exactly how a
ball moves you may not be thinking the
physics of it but you're watching it and
perceiving it because of that perception
you know something that you cannot know
by reading 100 books about it why does
one person need a
well my prescription these days eight
hours is it seven seventy eight hours
seven hours sleep okay seven hours
and why another person can do with half
of that
see one thing is
as we already went through the very
physical body that you carry is just the
food that you've eaten isn't it
you are looking at Food only as protein
vitamin mineral like this
but we're talking about a food chain
that means they're all different kinds
of lives
what we consume is another form of life
every animal consumes another form of
life this is the way the food cycle is
created
so in what condition that life is will
determine
in what condition your life is in many
ways
so you food appears in front of me if I
just look at it people have provided
with elaborate care if I just look at it
I say no
this lady has brought it she's a very
good cook she's very tasty I just look
it in a channel
simply because he's not alive enough for
me it may be tasty but it's not alive
enough for me
if it's not alive enough I will not
consume if you're just conscious of this
one thing
you will see your sleep quota will go
down
another thing is most people are eating
at least 50 percent 50 means hundred
percent more than what they need to eat
yes you you will do one thing as an
experiment just try this whatever you're
eating cut it down by 50 percent
if you're eating let's say uh two
kilograms of food cut it down to one
kilogram and eat variety of foods you
will see you will neither drop weight
nor will you become weak nor will you
become less energetic only thing that
will happen is your sleep quota will go
down
because you're putting so much food to
generate the same same amount of energy
you're eating more by compulsion of
liking the taste or simply by compulsion
of filling yourself up now the body has
to press process so much food to create
so much energy this extra processing is
taking a toll on the system
the amount of impurities that are there
in the food will also determine how how
much inertia you generate in the body
let's understand it this way in terms of
physical terms what sleep means is
inertia right now your Dynamic this is
life inertia said sin when inertia goes
beyond a certain point that's death
but sleep is a certain kind of death but
it is offering you rest
so restfulness is very important
what is being restful means is
if you sit here if you are a total ease
you will see the body is naturally
restful if you have you noticed on a
particular day you are very happy on
that day you don't need much sleep or
food have you noticed this
that's all you have to do
if you remain very joyful every moment
of your life the food will come down
sleep will come down naturally the
notion of the difference between pain
and suffering I thought was very useful
it's a pain is physiological it's there
it was no pain most people would not
even know how to protect themselves
see just because there's no pain and
they see what all you have done to it
isn't it see there's no pain in this so
that's why you took it off if there's no
pain in your nose
maybe you would have taken it off right
because the many advantages you will
take in about 22 extra oxygen if you
just remove this one thing contraption
[Laughter]
wherever there is no pain people are
messing with it like crazy isn't it they
call this hairstyle they call it so many
things yeah
Suppose there was no pain in the entire
body in Los Angeles
people would pull out their stomach bag
and
you think they wouldn't do it no that's
probably what
only pain is helping them to preserve
themselves isn't it so pain is good
there's no physiological pain most
people would not know I hear in United
States there's one group they call
themselves something I forget that word
they're actually cutting their fingers
off their hands off on the video
wow they're posting it online
there's a group like that whoa can you
imagine this no in spite of so much pain
if there was no pain almost everybody
would have cut themselves off into in
the name of fashion they would have cut
themselves into ribbons wow
so pain is a good thing physically
because that is your
preservation self-preservation mechanism
but suffering is something that you do
in your mind
so pain that happens in your body you
take it in your mind and multiply it a
thousand times or a million times
depending on how capable you are or how
stupid you are and suffer it a million
times over
right now most human beings are like
this what happened 10 years ago they can
still suffer
what may happen day after tomorrow they
already suffer
they are not suffering life they think
they are suffering life they are not
suffering life they are suffering the
two most fantastic faculties that human
beings alone have a vivid sense of
memory and a fantastic sense of
imagination I don't know I never looked
at Life as a series of mistakes learning
from that I don't look at life like that
well
have you done made some dumb decisions
here and there of course
I wouldn't see them as mistakes I just
see them as part of growing up and
becoming more mature because
Enlightenment is one thing you see
things clearly but still operating in
the world you need wisdom wisdom you
have to earn it with experience there is
simply no other way for that today it
has become fashionable with all these
management gurus and all saying You must
learn from your mistakes you must learn
mistakes that means you must keep on
doing mistakes I don't believe that you
must learn from your mistakes I would
rather live a life where I don't do any
mistakes
because life is so brief you do a bunch
of mistakes and then you will learn and
where will you use it in the grave
yeah and yes of
yes human means means that we can learn
from other people's experience from
history we can learn we don't have to do
all those things once again and
especially you are from the aviation
state if you are trying Aviation or if
you're trying skydiving or something if
you don't do things right the first time
well that will be the last time don't
utter the word freedom because freedom
is a consequence it's something that you
have to earn it doesn't come as a
philosophy in 60s we thought it's a
philosophy
if you live responsibly you will see
Freedom will come when I say responsibly
not in the sense of civic responsibility
if you retain your ability to respond to
life
without any prejudice
without any restriction you will see you
will become free
your ability to respond if it is
unlimited it is freedom there are many
aspects to this fundamentally if you
keep your life energies very exuberant
now you will see the slip quota will
naturally come down to keep it exuberant
you should not be over LED
largely in the ashram everybody young
people also eat only two meals a day 10
in the morning seven in the evening
our activity
exceeds most people's activity in the
world and we are seven days 365 days we
don't know what's a vacation because
we're enjoying what we're doing
we don't want a break
so they never go on a vacation there is
no break there's no Sunday Monday
nonsense nothing every day something is
happening endlessly
but you will see people are very
energetic healthy sleep is very little
so energetically a human being can be at
different levels why this is important
is
see what we call as life is just a
combination of two things a certain
amount of energy and a certain amount of
time
when it comes to time it is ticking away
for all of us at the same Pace flock
doesn't run slowly for me faster for you
there's no such thing
whether you are busy you are lazy you're
sleeping you're doing useful things or
useless things it doesn't matter what
you do or you do not do
time is ticking away
so there's no such thing as time
management
you can manage your energy
if you raise your energy to a higher
pitch of intensity what somebody does in
10 years you may do it in one year
so if you live for 100 years it looks
like you lived for a thousand years
simply because your energy is pitched up
this every human being can do
the whole yogic system is one dimension
of yogic system is just towards this if
you sit here even if you simply sit here
with your eyes closed you don't sit here
in a static way
you sit here in a dynamic way
you never become Static because static
is called as death
if everything becomes static that is
death if inertia really sets in that is
death so sleep in yoga is seen as death
you die every day how long do you want
to die in a day
you really must use this word for
yourself don't tell anybody I'm going to
die for yourself how long do I want to
die in a day eight hours a day if you
die
one third of your life you did
in 24 hours 8 hours your day means one
third of your life dead another four
hours goes into eating sleeping eating
toilet bath this that where is the time
to live I'm asking
so if life is precious
the most important thing to do is keep
your energies in an exuberant way so
that
life becomes more life feels enhanced
because you cannot enhance time one
thing is
the survival processes become easier
than ever before
believe me in the morning if you need a
bucket full of water if you had to walk
a mile to the river to get one bucket of
water
and your family needed 25 buckets of
you would have no time to mess yourself
now you have a lot of time to message
yourself because our survival is better
organized than ever before another thing
is most human beings do not know how to
manage their biochemistry without
physical activity
I have seen a whole lot of people
particularly teenage boys and girls
between the ages of 12 and 16 who come
to me with some severe violent problems
within themselves if you leave them like
that they may kill themselves or kill
somebody else they're in that kind of
state
many of them have even killed their
parents you know it just happened all
over the world and in 2017 when I came
to know that in India which is not so
much suicidal in that sense because
there's a huge family support and stuff
like that in spite of that in 2017 18
600 children below 18 years of age
committed suicide
out of which 7200 are below 15 years of
age
so 12 13 14 year olds
who must be bubbling with life or
wanting to take their own lives why
obviously we're doing something
fundamentally wrong with the society
isn't it yes our goals and our stupid
ideas of what is success is driving them
nuts
[Music]
because we are trying to use our
children like race horses that's
interesting
and when you say that as something to
that represent us that we've turned into
something amazing or in what way are
they like racehorses see when you
understand Life as a race
if you're in a race what's the objective
you must reach the Finish Line quick
isn't it
yes what is the finish line of your life
death
there you have it this may not be a
conscious process but life within you is
understanding it like that when you see
you must understand this whether you are
conscious of conscious of it or not any
human being
right now if you make yourself miserable
you must understand you are sending a
message to every cell in the body that I
don't want to live
you might not have articulated it in
your head yet
but when you become miserable you notice
suddenly your body seems heavy and it's
like doesn't want to get up from this
chair
have you seen this yes when you're happy
you're willing to bounce at everything
and do everything Bend backwards if
necessary
why this is happening is the message is
gone to every cell in the body this guy
wants to die
they're all thinking okay what can we do
to help him but by then of course you
recover
so you want to die you want to live you
want to die you want to live
the body is getting confused
because you must understand this is a
very intelligent body it's taking
instructions from you
every cell in the body has enormous
sense of memory and intelligence
if you keep sending wrong messages if
they act you did
because you're sending contradictory
messages you are not dead you're half
dead
you can give it any number of exotic
names essentially you have turned your
intelligence against yourself
this is supposed to work for you but now
you turn it against yourself it's
working against you first of all people
are assuming that anger is happening to
them or misery is happening to them no
this is exactly what I said earlier
maybe I didn't articulate it fully no
you are creating anger you are creating
misery you're creating Joy you're
creating whatever all this is happening
from within you but Human Experience is
happening from within us isn't it right
whether it's love or hate or anger or
misery or Joy or anything is only
happening from within us now simple
question I am asking is what happens
from within you should you have should
it happen your way or somebody else's
way
it should happen your way
of course because the world will never
happen your way 100 percent
because there are so many stakeholders
in the world little bit will happen my
way little bit your way that is fine but
what happens Within Me must happen my
way if what happens within me does not
happen my way this is the worst form of
slavery isn't it wow
somebody decides what happens within me
somebody decides where I should sit this
is slavery everybody understands this
now somebody decides whether I am
happier and happy isn't this the worst
form of slavery yeah
so this is The Liberation that Humanity
needs to work at this is what inner
engineering means inner engineering is
not some mechanical process because
engineering means this essentially you
will say something is well engineered
only if it works the way you want isn't
it
if this one doesn't work the way you
want what the hell are you expecting
other things to work the way you want
it's just an accident when you live
accidentally anxiety is normal he or she
is hot
now they say
you must see this one come here
come here come here
you must see how she's laughing at every
joke huh
[Applause]
she's cool people think I have knowledge
no my head is empty that's why to make
look little substantial I have a turbine
it's totally empty always but I have
Clarity Clarity means what you see
things the way they are knowledge means
what you have fixed information about
everything if the things have changed
you will not see it the way it is that's
as good as being blind say people think
owls are blind it's not true their
vision is far more sensitive than yours
but because of sunlight they're blinded
because it's too much when light goes
down he sees very clearly not because
he's blind because his eyes are super
sensitive so it's important that you
bring Clarity to your life not knowledge
because knowledge is conclusions that
you gather knowledge is okay when you're
trying to do something physical material
in the world but not with life
is it true
what you thought was absolute at the age
of 12 today is not true
yes or no
are you sure that whatever you think is
this is it right now will be this is it
in another three years time of course
not
you know that so you know you're wrong
[Music]
yes sir no
so you know anyway you're wrong so why
assert the wrong things
well right now we are wrong at least
let's manage with little
little more conscious if you know you're
wrong you will walk carefully isn't it
hello
but you you think you're absolutely
correct
then you will do stupid things and you
blunder around the world
if you know you're not seeing properly
will you walk carefully or no
if I asked you to walk through a dark
room suppose we turn off all the lights
and close it down everything pitch dark
if I ask you to walk suddenly will you
become super alert and conscious as to
how you walk
but when the lights are on
you just going unconsciously bumping
into everybody
so if you learn to walk every moment
like there are no lights and you're
looking at everything absolutely
carefully
then what you see clearly you go through
it what you don't see see clearly you
hesitate some places you take a little
bit of chance
but if you are just confident
you will blunder through life we don't
know where you will get in and what you
will get trapped into
most people are trapped into their
professions their family situations
their social situations in such a way
they all became like
yes already I'm seeing
not just older people youth have become
like this
what will happen to me at the end of my
life what will happen to me at the end
of my life I'm already revealed the
secret you will die
foreign
what to do if that happens what to do
all those things will happen
it's not that everything will happen in
your life the way you like it things
will happen in the way you don't like it
it once happened Shankar and pillai got
fired from his job
simply because he asked a question
smoking or not smoke non-smoking
how can you get fired for asking such a
simple question
smoking or non-smoking he asked and he
got fired
because what he was supposed to ask was
cremation or burial
so many times what you do thinking I am
right may be irrelevant to the situation
in which you exist
so the most important aspect of your
life is your relevant
not right
you're just relevant to the existing
situation you're relevant I am right I
am right I am right
this is confidence
you being right nobody cares all the
idiots who think they are right nobody
wants to listen to them nobody wants to
be around them isn't it
people who always think I am right I am
right you want to be around them
no the important thing is you're
relevant to the situation in which you
exist if you have to bring relevance
into your life you must extinguish your
confidence and bring Clarity you should
not be a motivated person
generally somebody when we say somebody
is motivated
it means they have an agenda of Their
Own
Life Has No Agenda it's for you to be a
full-fledged life a grasshopper is
trying to be a full-fledged grasshopper
earthworm is trying to be a full-fledged
earthworm a bird is trying to be a
full-fledged bird a tree is trying to be
a full-fledged tree a human being should
strive to become a full-fledged human
being
is all our businesses
but each one of us start creating our
own agendas
and doing all kinds of things no no
you're just a piece of life don't take
yourself too seriously
because before you and me countless
number of people have come and gone
yes or no
where are they
all those people
you think they were all idiots
they were all idiots and they died is it
no they were also like you maybe they
were also officers maybe they were Kings
more than you all kinds of things
all topsoil now
this will also become top soil
just a little bit of time life is a bit
of a sparkle
[Music]
how old is your sunshine
25.
so 27 years ago where was he sir
so if somebody is not here we say
they're dead isn't it
27 years ago he was dead
we will give him 100 Years sir 80 years
later
he will be again dead
[Music]
yes or no
so 27 years ago how long was he dead sir
huh
[Music]
long time
so 85 years later or 80 years later how
long will he be dead sir
very long time
so all of us will be dead for a very
long time
they're alive just for a brief amount of
time
yes very brief amount of time
we will be dead for a very long time I
want you to look at it in this
perspective how long will you be dead
you can't imagine so let us say
10 000 years we are dead or 100 000
years they are dead or a million years
we are dead all right
how long are you alive compared to that
very very brief what you call is life is
a brief Sparkle the only thing that you
have to do is rise and Sparkle as a
full-fledged life
when something is needed around us we
will do that naturally because when
you're doing wonderfully well you will
do what is needed isn't it
when you're miserable you will be
motivated
yes
tell me when you are very happy have you
looked at yourself how nice and
wonderful you are you're willing to do
anything for anybody Bend backwards if
necessary yes or no
when you're little frustrated
whoa
how difficult it is so don't teach your
children to become motivated about
something these are all nonsense that's
coming from the West all those trashy
self-help books motivate yourself build
confidence believe in yourself you
believed in God and destroyed so much of
this world now you believe in yourself
what will you do when Gautama
the Buddha was asked
is it better to walk alone
or in company
he said
it's better to walk alone than to walk
with a fool
well
that's him not me
he was quite sure that only a fool will
walk with you
so he said it's better to walk alone
than to walk with the fool
certain lore in this country
says
when you want to do a short and quick
Journey Walk Alone
when you want to do a long journey walk
in company
but the important thing is
who is walking with you
not always being together is a good
thing
many times
being together can be a nuisance
so
first and foremost
unless you are a twin
even then
we come along and we go along
if one does not know
how to be by himself
or herself
then being together can be a lot of
nuisance
we are referred to as human beings
human beings means
every other creature
is what it is simply because of what he
does
but a human being can simply be
which is a unique quality of the human
being that we can simply be that we are
not compulsive action that's what it
means
our action is conscious and judicious
but generally when people get together
generally people are in compulsive
action
it can be an association where there
could be a purposeful action
or it can be a gang where there can be
more purposeful action
or it can be a crowd which can be a
compulsive action
so essentially to be human means
we have reached that point of evolution
within ourselves
that if we wish we can simply sit here
just be
we can consider
as to what action to take and what not
to take
this is definitely individual
when individuals come together
we say
it's we in
in plural
but still it is individuals who have to
come together
to be an individual means
you are not further divisible
that means you're just one
people find different ways to divide
themselves within themselves
in India with eight ten thousand years
of cultural history
we have invented various words to divide
ourselves
it's very common for people to talk in
terms of Atma paramatma Ankara this one
and that one
but every every culture has this in
their own way
when things are going right
when good things are being done if you
ask people they say yes I did it
when things don't go right when things
go wrong
then they will try to find somebody if
they don't find anybody
he is always there
when they are very wonderful
of course they take pride in being how
wonderful they are
when they turn nasty they say it was my
ego
Mr ego is always a Fall Guy
so individual means
but if I'm wonderful it's me if I am
nasty it's me all of you
are you 24 hours wonderful
hello
no no sometimes wonderful sometimes
nasty sometimes beautiful sometimes ugly
it's okay
if we understand it is me who is capable
of being absolutely wonderful and it is
me who is capable of being absolutely
nasty another moment
then gradually the number of moments of
nastiness will keep on receding
if I see
what is wonderful is me what is nastiest
in India we have many words it's my
karma what can I do
now you must fix this
being an individual is very important
that means you're not further divisible
if I am wonderful it's me if I'm nasty
it's me
if I succeed it's me if I fail it's me
you have to fix this
learn to be like God
never intervene in anything
every day in the morning
every kind of idiot will tell you what
you should do today
you just listen
just like God
marriage will work it may not work with
your profession
say yeah
you're misunderstanding this
you're trying to make this into some
kind of a value system
you're trying to make it your philosophy
I will do only what works
[Music]
well you took a oath I will do only what
works now you don't know what works
because what we what works will not come
with a oath
or a commandment what works comes with
constant observation and evolution of
who you are isn't it
hello
the same things how you made them work
how clumsily you made something work 10
years ago the same thing you may be
doing it with ease today isn't it so
or you may be doing it clumsily today
you're doing it well at one time
whichever way whichever kind of
evolution has happened
so what works
is not some kind of a formula
it is an evolution of a human being to
come to what works on all levels of life
okay
uh
this is like really I mean you you're
just falling out of a self-help book
no I am not a self-help book
do what works do whatever the hell you
want
what's my problem
but what's the point of doing something
that doesn't work
hello
I'm not telling you you should do only
what works do whatever the hell you want
but for your life because it's a limited
amount of time
what is the point doing something that
does not work isn't it
either it should work for you or it
should work for people around you if it
doesn't work for you and anybody around
you what is the point of doing that damn
thing
this happened
soldiers American soldiers were leaving
on duty
so
one of them told the other
you know Steve's wife
she read Three Musketeers and she
delivered a triple delivered triplets
he says oh my God my wife is reading
Birth of a Nation
what am I supposed to do
that's not how it works
so don't make this into some kind of an
ethic or a philosophy I will do only
what works
well just to see what works needs lot of
application even for the smallest damn
things isn't it hello
to do a smallest thing
like hitting a ball or kicking a ball
straight
you know
how much it takes
somebody who can take a ball where he
wants wow the whole world is worshiping
him
just because he kicks a damn ball
yes or no
because people understand what it takes
nobody is worshiping worshiping him
because he kicks a ball because people
can see what has gone into it
isn't it so
people can see what has gone into
be able to kick a ball the way he is
kicking what has gone into it his life
has gone into it
so don't make philosophies and ethics
out of everything or don't tell yourself
a commandment
I will do only what works
it's a good commandment
but now you don't know what works
so
no no
you
you need to be conscious and apply
yourself to every damn thing
you should just learn this much
that you don't decide what is important
and what is not important I would say
this literally no human being
who is not confronted with a thought and
an emotion like that
but they managed to brush us aside it
doesn't bother them enough
the pain of not knowing doesn't tear
them that's the whole problem
they come to terms with ignorance they
make a deal with ignorance they will
build relationships where everybody will
confirm this is the best way to live
off Comfort companionship love affection
these are all things you're seeking I
know a whole lot of people have raised
human emotions to Heavens if you say
love they say Divine love if you say Joy
they say Divine Joy if you say Bliss
they say Divine Bliss
you don't need any God's help to be
joyful loving peaceful
as a human being you end out with these
qualities
so all those who deprived themselves of
that they either seek
God or they settle for a dog
yeah usually
because
they want a unconditional love this is a
demand
because the nature of Love is such that
it's like a flower if you don't watch it
for two minutes It'll fall
it'll wither and fall right there
either you want to
let it fall
or you have to nourish it every moment
or you have to concretize it that means
you take a picture and keep it on your
phone screen
or you institutionalize it with marriage
or this or that
so essentially
well I'm I'm not against any institution
because institutions are needed in the
world to operate otherwise there will be
chaos
that is a different thing but you cannot
institutionalize Joy or peace like right
now we think United Nations is the
institution for peace no no you cannot
institutionalize peace
you cannot institutionalize Joy you
cannot institutionalize love or anything
for that matter institutions are
functional instruments in a given
Society I have utmost respect for them
because without it people a whole lot of
people wouldn't know how to live
you need institutions there is a
government there is a democratic process
there are a variety of things all right
there are quotes there are parliaments
well ninety percent of the time some
nonsense may be happening there but
still these institutions are important
because without that there will be total
chaos
so I'm not talking against institutions
but institutionalizing things that
happen within a human being
is a silly effort in the yoga culture
first eight years
or actually eight and a half years
is considered childhood
so these are not counted though
balavastha is up to 12. it's the eight
and a half years where you're a real
child you know it from your own
experience after you're eight and a half
only your parents thought you were a
child but you were secretly many things
yes
adults think that you are a child but
you know you are not one
because your childhood in many ways ends
at eight and a half
so if you take two side solar Cycles
which is uh
24 years or little less than that
and add eight and a half years to it
it will become
32 and 3 4 or something like this
32 years in seven months are somewhere
there
exact calculations we can make but it's
nearly 33 years
so when these two cycles end
the balavastha
living that when it ends
it is a possibility
this is a time when your life could take
on a different level of propulsion
if you have prepared yourself well
either with education or some skill or
yoga or
inner dimensions of your life if you
have prepared yourself on any of these
things that is the time when it can
Propel or that is the time when it can
start crashing
you know in the western societies they
talk about mid-life crisis
it usually starts around 33 34 years of
age
suddenly people don't know what to do
with themselves
life getting meaningless or those who
are successful they find
traction and suddenly they explode into
different levels of success or
well-being
all this can happen
because
within the system it has completed a
certain cycle either it can take off or
it can crash let one human being
honestly say
when you are with your most loving
parents however doting and wonderful
they were to you
that you never felt this is not where
you want to be
that is a dishonest human being
because
love gets tedious
somebody's fondness gets very tedious
Comfort gets tedious
because the nature of life is it wants
to constantly expand
if there is no room for expansion it
doesn't matter you are kept in a uh
whatever I won't use because everybody
uses the word Golden Palace I think
Golden Palace is totally anesthetic in
my uh
my visual perception I hate Golden
Palace but whatever is the most
wonderful Palace
or as you say Shangri-La whatever
you will it'll get tedious
all the heaven-bound people
they don't know how bored they will be
within three days in that place of
goodness
so I am saying it doesn't matter it's
not because there's something wrong with
your parents
they may be most wonderful people
but
the very nature of a human being is such
only if you are a pet animal
if you have reduced yourself to that
you're just happy
with the means that you're getting and
somebody is fondling you once in a way
and you're happy with that
for that you must be a pet animal you
should not be born as a human being once
you're born as a human being it is
natural wanting to break
barriers so when you're young as a child
or a teenager you think barriers means
they're all physical before you
understand the barriers are not really
physical whether you build your own
house or you live in your parents house
or you live in a slave master's house
the house and walls are not the barrier
it is all within us before you realize
that or how soon you realize that will
lead to either transformation or
frustration you can simply sit
if you learn to simplicit
you will become tremendously intense
right now your energy simply expanded by
doing unnecessary
endless activity
when you have so much
mental diarrhea how can you have energy
suppose you have diarrhea do you see how
weak you feel yes or no right now this
mental diarrhea that's why people have
no energy
they want to just eat and sleep all the
time because mental diarrhea is very
exhausting
[Music]
if you have physical diarrhea you know
how exhausting it is yes
this is also equally exhausting
people are sleeping eight hours ten
hours a day
not because they are working so much or
their body is in such a bad state
it's just mental diarrhea
if you stop the mental diarrhea there's
enough energy to make this very very
intense
now how do I stop mental area
if you have diarrhea physical diarrhea
what is the first thing to do
what
yes run to the toilet I know that
all right
as a as a corrective measure what is the
first thing you do
no as a corrective measure what is the
[Music]
but diarrhea means in some way we've
eaten something that the body doesn't
want
it's trying to throw it out
yes
you've taken something inside which the
body doesn't like it wants to throw it
out
first thing is
[Music]
stay away from food for some time
you eat bad food and then try to stop
diarrhea it's not going to work
so similarly bad food for the mind is
just this
you have gotten identified with things
that you are not
the moment you get identified with
things that you are not
mental diarrhea is inevitable
it's bad food for the mind now it will
run endlessly do what you want you do
any damn meditation you say Shiva Rama
it's not going to stop
it's not stopped isn't it
because bad food is being eaten every
day you're getting identified with more
and more things and you want to stop
your mind
you do whatever kind of circus
it is not going to stop
if you disidentify with everything
if you understand what is you and what
is not you
if you keep a little distance from that
mind will become still
if you want you can use it otherwise you
can keep it
now my hand is there if I want I can
move it otherwise I can keep it this is
a useful hand suppose it starts jumping
like this
okay
you clearly know
there is some kind of an ailment isn't
it
yes or no
so if hand is jumping you know it's an
ailment if mind is jumping is it an
ailment or no
the element has come because continuous
wrong diet
you tell your mind that I am this I am
this I am that I am that
he's having diarrhea
you stop giving it wrong food
if you clearly see what even if you do
not know what is me at least you know
what is not me isn't it
this much you do
tonight before you go to bed
sit on your bed
and sit down and discount everything
that is not you
this house in Europe in which you're
living is this me
no
this loving parent or mother father wife
or husband or child
they're wonderful but is this me
no
no these nice clothes I'm wearing is
this me no
now my body I like it but is this me no
now I am having so many thoughts is this
me no
now I'm having wonderful emotions is
this me no
like this everything that's not you
before you sleep keep it down and go to
bed
tomorrow morning you will wake up
considerably more intense than today
this happened in your school maybe later
in your University later in your work
it's happening to people maybe not
everyone but a whole lot of people
their commitment to success is weak
they want to succeed they will take
three steps then something little
interesting happens here they will go
away here they'll go over there they'll
go with it hey I want to live
foreign
[Music]
situations can impede you from doing
what you're doing very easily many times
it happens to everyone
but when this happens people weaken
their commitment for their success
maybe physically they'll feel a little
weak
they will weaken their commitment to
success maybe their emotions loss around
a little bit
they will weaken their commitment to
success
this is very important right now
however long it takes this virus
you must come out of this successfully
that means you will stay alive that's an
important part
[Music]
and
commitment to staying alive
should not be slackened no matter what
happened somebody very dear to us passed
away all the more important we must live
[Music]
people around us are all sick all the
more important we are healthy
to take care of the people around us
so our commitment to success should not
weaken because there is social drama
going on or physiological drama or
psychological drama whatever happens
your commitment to success should not
weaken that is what get you across so
many lines in our life so many barriers
in our life
so uh what does success look like
what does it take
[Music]
you must understand
those who made any significant
achievements in their life
uh they did not
you know
I don't want to take any personal
examples of anybody I'm trying to avoid
obvious things that are coming to my
mind
well
you know I know
family and friends
who always have their breakfast on time
and after breakfast of course they must
have coffee
after coffee of course they must light
up a cigarette and sit there nicely
because they're trying to
become peaceful
[Music]
and then they will go to work
come back home exactly on time for lunch
eat lunch
rest for one or two hours sleep
then evening have on tea and then smoke
and then again go to work
and at eight eight o'clock 8 30 they're
back home for dinner and then maybe
other things drink and this and that and
whatever
thank you
well that's their priority
it's fine I'm not complaining it should
not be that way
but those who have been very successful
either in music sport art business
spiritual process doesn't matter what
those people
never know when they hate when they
slept when they got afternoon rest I
have not seen such a thing in my life
so uh uh
those who are committed to being
successful with whatever they are doing
one important aspect of their life is
they are not settling down wherever it's
a bit comfortable
because Comfort will happen when they
lower you to in the grave very
comfortable you are you know hello
so just do this one thing stop
discriminating what is important what is
not important
if you pay the same level of absolute
attention to every damn thing you will
see
that what is the right thing to do is a
very natural process
but you have already decided what is
important what is not important how will
you evolve what is the right thing to do
half the world is already been given up
because it's not important
you are paying attention only you even
look at somebody properly only if they
are of something to you
no I looked at everybody absolutely
every life every damn thing every Pebble
every moment that was happening in the
earth in the atmosphere everything not
as a study
simply because I had eyes
and I had an attention span I paid
attention to everything today they are
saying this is something phenomenal I
was just laughing and saying see I just
wandered aimlessly everybody thought I
am just a vagabond but now this aimless
wandering has is paying off in a huge
way
because it doesn't matter what the hell
you're doing small things are big things
if you are absolutely involved
absolutely
you will see you will know what's the
right thing to do
you trying to live here without
involvement this is why you have morals
you have ideals you have ideologies you
have values you have ethics you have
Commandments
because you are trying to live here
without involvement
you want ready-made formula what is the
right thing to do thou shall not thou
shall not thou shall not did the world
get fixed I'm asking
every goddamn school-going children
knows what is the right thing to do has
it worked
it's not worked because you think there
is a substitute for involvement
there is no substitute for involvement
where there is no involvement there will
be no life
so don't try to make formulas
or ideals or ideologies out of life all
life takes is absolute involvement
unbridled involvement not distinguishing
who is who what is what just absolutely
involved with everything that you're in
touch with right now
if you do this one thing
program according to your level of
intelligence
and
you know nature also should yield
with all this
you will know what is the best thing to
do given your perspective of course
see right now if you bring a man of
certain capability
he may do something in a given situation
that's not the right thing to do for you
isn't it
you must know what is the right thing
for you to do in a given situation you
won't be able to do what he does you
must be able to do what you can do to
the best of your ability that is the
right thing to do in your life
you don't try to do like somebody else
so that will be the problem the moment
you decide what is the right thing to do
now
there is no ready-made solution
involvement
there is no substitute for environment
where there is no involvement there is
no life
this happened in 1941.
this is just when the Nazi moment was
building up in Germany and
in some parts of Europe so one day in
Austria
a bunch of German soldiers came broke
into the homes
the Jewish Family a rich family they
broke the home and took away the adults
took everything was robbed
and these two children a 12 year old
girl and a eight-year-old boy were taken
away they were taken to a railway
station
this is the month of November and
December kind of time when it's becoming
very cold
so they were kept in the railway station
for three days because the trains did
not come boys little boys being boys
they started playing football
so they were playing football and then
suddenly the train came
the train is not a passenger train it's
a cargo train a good train
so when the train came the soldiers came
and rushed everybody into the
the wagons which are there
everybody got in and the little boy and
the girl also got in but the little boy
forgot to wear his shoes he left his
shoes outside and they pushed him into
the wagon so without shoes he came
his sister a 12 year old girl saw her
kid brother coming without shoes and she
got mad with him she held him by the
year boxed his ears scolded him nicely
slapped him
he said you eat it already we are in
enough trouble now you come without
shoes because in Germany in Winter no
shoes means you may lose your feet
so she's angry about that in the next
station the boys and girls were
separated
after four years
after the war was over she came out of
the concentration camp
to find 17 members of her family
including her little brother all had
vanished no records no sign of them they
just evaporated
at that time
the only thing that bothered her was the
last few things that she said to her
little brother
she loves her brother but the last few
things that she said to him were such
terrible things it rang in her mind
and troubled her these are the last
things I told my brother and after that
I'm never going to see him he's gone
so she took a wow
if I speak to anybody in my life I will
speak in such a way if this is my last
word I will not regret
this one thing transformed her life in
such a way she went on to United States
she died in 2006. she did some
phenomenal work built a hospital
somewhere near Chicago I think
she lived a fruitful life I am saying
even if you put through the most
horrible situations
either you can come out using that
experience as a better human being or
you can use the experience to become a
horrible mess
so whenever something hurts you there
are two options
you can either become wounded
or you can become wise this is the
choice
the more things hurt you early on in
your life the wiser you should have
become isn't it
but unfortunately most people become
wounded
this is simply because they just need an
excuse to turn their own intelligence
against themselves that's all
especially if the world around you turns
against you is it not very very
important that your intelligence stands
up for you because you may
you might want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for 10 more amazing rules from
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there problems happen
challenges happen struggles happen
issues happen misunderstandings
crisis has happened Financial crunches
happen markets go down and that happens
all of that happens